we're continuing to see the
deterioration of Donald Trump's ability
to think and to speak and to sort of
turn what's in his brain into words that
other humans can understand I mean I'm
almost struggling to explain what it is
that we're seeing because it's so
disturbing Donald Trump had another one
of these speeches where even the
teleprompter couldn't make him sound
coherent we've seen this before take a
look at Donald Trump speaking the other
day slow slurring sniffing huffing and
puffing confused unclear if he even
knows what it is that he's reading off
of his teleprompter noticed that when
the camera zooms out he sort of seems to
be strangely leaning on and clutching
the lectern I mean every element of this
audio and video is unusual have budgets
since we came into the administration
since the election of 2016
since January 20th of 2013 hundred
billion seven hundred and sixteen
billion and now seven hundred and thirty
eight billion dollars nobody would have
thought that that was possible but we
had them approved by Republicans and
Democrats and that money is now building
the most advanced equipment anywhere on
earth equipment that nobody even could
have conceived of even two years ago put
aside for a second that nothing he's
saying is true or makes sense
there is much else going on here this
could be someone who's normally on
uppers coming down or on an off day
that's one type of possibility this
could be continued cognitive decline
which we've been talking about this
could just be an exhausted 73 year-old
who simply can't keep up with the
demands of being president because he is
obese in terrible shape it could be
anything but it's not normal and it's
not good for the country and as a
reminder
Aaron Roop are from Vox posted this
video to Twitter the deterioration can
be hard to notice day to day when you
hear Trump every day you might not
notice how much he has fallen off in
terms of his speaking abilities but look
at Trump during his presidential
campaign in 2015 which was already a far
cry from what the guy was twenty years
ago but still comparatively quick spry
agile the opposite of 2019 Trump because
I don't need anybody's money it's nice I
don't need anybody's money I'm using my
own money I'm not using the lobbyists
I'm not using donors I don't care I'm
really rich I'll show you that in a
second and by the way I'm not even
saying that in a braggart that's the
kind of mindset that's the kind of
thinking you need for this as a reminder
if that is not enough contrast here's
the famous incident the United States of
America god bless the Palestinians and
Jerusalem oh we which was initially I
guess attributed to loose dentures which
we later found out from doesn't even
wear let us rethink old assumptions and
open our hearts and minds to possible
and possibilities and finally I asked
the leaders of the region politically
religious
Israeli and Palestinian Jewish and
Christian and Muslim to join us in the
noble quest for lasting peace thank you
god bless you god bless Israel God bless
the Palestinians and God bless the
United States thank you very much it's
not just the slurring okay to be clear
when this happens Trump seems not to
recognize what he is reading or what he
is saying this is very serious stuff if
you look at a close-up of Donald Trump's
face during some of these incidents he
actually sort of seems to be chewing on
his tongue or having trouble getting his
tongue out of the way or in a position
where it doesn't hinder his speech he's
acting almost like he has full-on
novocaine from dental work or something
very odd this is not a joke this is not
political this is just very serious the
Trump
pain is politicizing it they are sending
lackeys around to Fox News to claim that
Joe Biden is actually having cognitive
issues now I covered the Joe Biden stuff
last week I as I said I would be a
hypocrite if I point out when this stuff
is going on with Donald Trump I would be
a hypocrite if I didn't point it out
when it's happening with Joe Biden but
Trump's the president not a candidate
for one of the nominations for president
and Trump's having the same issues but
10 times over Ted to to a significantly
greater magnitude check out Trump 2020
director of strategic communications
Marc Lauder on Fox News just playing
politics and talking about Joe Biden
well unfortunately I know a lot of
people say these are gaffes but it's
clearly a problem with Joe Biden I mean
he gets about every detail wrong in a
couple of minutes about this war story
he can't remember who the Prime Minister
of the United Kingdom is he couldn't
remember what state he was in a couple
of weeks ago I mean these are not gaffes
it is a problem with Joe Biden and it's
causing a lot of Democrats to start to
rethink their frontrunner
this is just too serious for
partisanship I don't know what other way
I can say it Biden might have something
going on we're talking about it it was
weird when he seemed to forget President
Obama's name it's been weird when he's
misstated the state that he's in or when
different things happened or whatever
else the case may be Trump has a very
public and very visible multi-year
decline of the same type of stuff that
we've seen from Biden but worse many
times greater Trump leaving a signing
ceremony without signing the thing he
was there does not to sign Trump walking
away from his limo he walks off of Air
Force One the limos right in front of
him Trump wanders off and has to be
physically pulled back by Secret Service
and redirected towards his car
Trump wondering where Rudy Giuliani is
when Giuliani is sitting directly in
front of them Trump saying we need to
find out the oranges of the
investigation almost as if he's now the
citrus detective of some kind rather
than the origins of the investigation
it's endless I could just list these
things for an hour if you care about the
country and recognize
agree maybe you don't agree but if you
agree you need a cognitively able person
in the Oval Office you need to be
questioning what it is that is happening
with Donald Trump I am open to any and
all suggestions as to what it is that
might be going on here and this was not
the only weird thing that happened over
the long Labor Day weekend and that's
what I want to talk about next there's
been a multi-year story that we've been
following and it's the story of brexit
and the primary question has been will
brexit happen or will it not is Britain
going to leave the European Union or are
they going to end up staying and as I
said the day after the vote June 23 2016
it may never happen Breck's it may never
happen and of course we now know that if
the vote were to be held again today
remain would likely win although there
are questions of listen they did vote
this way back in 2016 for how long does
that vote remain considered the will of
the people there are all sorts of
questions like that but more recently
there have been much more pressing sort
of obstacles the former prime minister
Teresa may multiple times attempting to
finalize a deal to structure the leaving
of the European Union and failing and
ultimately the question was was will she
be able to outlast the criticism and the
calls for her to leave and ultimately
she left and Boris Johnson came in Boris
Johnson trumpian in many ways certainly
physically in his physical appearance
although that's not the most important
way the leader of the Conservative Party
now the Prime Minister will he finally
do brexit for the Nationalists and the
isolationists who want the UK out of the
EU or will he also fail and so far it's
really not working particularly well for
him he has between having one Tory MP
defect and kicking 20 others out for not
supporting him he very quickly seems not
to have the numbers that he needs to get
to the next step in the brexit process
so bottom line there has been one
defection a Tory MP who bailed on Boris
Johnson's party 20 other Tory MPs
our Tories or at least they were but
they didn't go along with what Boris
Johnson wanted and they were ejected and
now all of a sudden Boris Johnson finds
himself and yet another one of these
embarrassing scenarios for the pro
brexit side giving the opposition
control of the agenda in Parliament
Johnson is soon going to have to face
those Prime Minister's Questions for the
first time which can get very very crazy
the opposition of course is going to
continue to try to delay brexit and
Boris Johnson may call for a general
election a really a devastating defeat
for Johnson I know that you know the
standards and the the sort of rules of
decorum and how to interpret political
happenings in different countries can be
difficult when we're not familiarized
with the system and for what the sort of
Overton Window is for what we can expect
in terms of what is possible on one side
on the other side but this is an
embarrassing defeat for Johnson here's
video from yesterday in Parliament where
members of Johnson's own party abandon
him and vote to allow a debate to once
again postpone brexit and the question
becomes does it seem as though this is
ultimately turning into an indefinite
postponement total chaos breaking out
take a look at the first clip the eyes
to the right
328 the nose to the left 301
[Applause]
not a good start varus order the eyes to
the right 328 the nose to the left 301
so the eyes of it the eyes have it a lot
of course point of order of the Prime
Minister Speaker I think
[Applause]
by the consequences of this vote tonight
it means that Parliament is on the brink
of wrecking any deal that we might be
able to scribe
and control of the negotiations to the
EU and that would mean more dither
more delay and more confusion themselves
would be able to decide how long to keep
this country in the ear and since I
refuse to go along with that plan we are
going to have to make a choice Mr
Speaker I don't want an election the
public an election but if the house
waits for this bill tomorrow the public
will have to choose who goes to Brussels
on October the 17th to sort this out and
take this country forward what I love
about the system is that Trump
definitely couldn't handle it and I'm
reminded of it because when you look at
Boris Johnson the look on he looks very
trumpian like I said but he has a
slightly more wits about him expression
on his face than Trump can you imagine
Donald Trump ever having to handle
something like this I mean the guy just
literally could not he'd implode and -
under this kind of actual intense
scrutiny and this continuing to build as
eventually Boris Johnson suffering
abandonments and real chaos breaks out
Jeremy Corbyn ultimately speaking there
is no consent in this house to leave the
European Union without a deal there is
no majority for no deal in the country
as I've said before if the Prime
Minister has the confidence in his
brexit policy when he has won he can put
forward he should put it before the
people in a public vote
so
he wants the table emotion for a general
election fine get the bill through
[Applause]
in order to take no deal off the table
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
very rude the members order order
but other I think the Chancellor of the
Duchy that when he turns up at our
children's school as a parent he's a
very well behaved fellow he wouldn't
dare behave like that in front of
Colleen all and neither would I danger
sticky late don't grant spare us the
theatrics behave yourself
[Applause]
things are really getting crazy and
what's even wackier is that this was all
merely a debate over what to order for
lunch no I'm kidding
but this I still believe in the end that
it is a likely scenario that the UK may
never leave the European Union if it
does it may not happen under Boris
Johnson the way his prime ministership
has been going in its very early days at
this point in time and we actually are
asking you what you think will
ultimately happen we've pulled our
audience every you know once a year or
so since this has gone down since the
vote went down in 2016 if you go to the
community tab on the david pakman show
youtube channel youtube.com slash the
david pakman show slash community do you
think the UK will ever actually brexit
we will have results either later this
week or maybe early next week alright so
I already mentioned at the top of the
show in the u.s. we had this long
holiday weekend for Labor Day the David
Pakman show was off we debuted a
long-form episode that we had previously
produced on healthcare so many Americans
because of the long holiday weekend
didn't hear or see the ridiculous and
embarrassing gong show of things that
Donald Trump said now unfortunately the
rest of the world didn't have a holiday
weekend or at least most countries
didn't maybe somebody did and thus they
did see and hear the absurdities that
came out of Donald Trump's mouth and out
of his Twitter account in the United
States the weekend saw the approach of
hurricane hurricane durian which is now
a made landfall the most powerful
hurricane on record at one point heading
to Florida South Carolina Georgia even
parts of North Carolina Hurricane Dorian
as of last night had already killed at
least five people by the time you hear
this unfortunately but realistically
that number may be even higher and
Donald Trump says I've never even heard
of a category 5 storm before there have
been 4 category 5 storms during his
presidency and
of course his reaction to the ones that
did damage and caused deaths in the past
were disastrous and atrocious reactions
and responses check this out what is he
talking about determined and resilient
and we will support each other and we
will work very hard to minimize whatever
the effect of what's coming at us we
don't even know what's coming at us all
we know is it's possibly the biggest I
am not sure I'm not sure that I've ever
even heard of the category five I knew
it existed and I've seen some category
force you don't even see them that much
but the category five is something that
when you've already been criticized for
your terrible responses to prior
hurricanes when Puerto Rico was hit or
why don't remember where it was that he
showed up and shot paper towel rolls
like basketballs like some kind of game
maybe that was Florida mitt maybe it was
Puerto Rico they're all kind of blending
together at this point because his
reaction to all of them was so horrible
and then you say who's even heard of
category five before you look even more
like you don't care when you say you've
never heard of an actual category five
storm coming and there were four during
your presidency you seem like you don't
give you know what about the people that
are affected by the hurricanes Trump has
said this before by the way he said in
October of 2017 who's even heard of a
category five hurricane hitting land
hurricanes
Irma Maria and Michael were at different
points in that in the evolution of those
storms category five and then Donald
Trump creating even more chaos by saying
Alabama is going to get hit Alabama was
not under threat Donald Trump tweeting
quote in addition to Florida South
Carolina North Carolina Georgia and
Alabama will most likely be hit much
harder than anticipated looking like one
of the largest hurricanes ever already
category five be careful god bless
everyone and of course in Alabama
nobody from actual weather services had
said you're fine
right I'm sorry nobody had said you're
not fine nobody has said you need to be
worried so Alabama immediately in a
panic officials
right away having to say hold on a
second the president is wrong you
everything's okay in Alabama Alabama you
don't have to evacuate you're going to
be okay and it's stunning that in the
Trump presidency
scientists have been refuting Trump on
climate for the entirety of his
presidency and even when he was just
candidate Trump and now even on weather
which pi though I know a lot of people
on the right are probably saying David
what are you talking about climate and
weather are the same thing no they're
not and in fact that's where a lot of
confusion about climate change comes
from but now weather service's having to
refute Donald Trump on the subject of
weather as well does Donald Trump have
any recollection of the things that have
happened during his presidency truly I
mean we talked earlier about cognitive
decline memory issues etc does he not
care to remember
or can he not remember is something
actually wrong with the guy's memory so
once again serious questions
increasingly being asked about would you
call this a narcissism issue is this a
memory issue is it a cognitive state
issue and we had I mean it's terrible
really we had yet another one of these
major red flag cognitive events with
Donald Trump over the weekend which I
talked about at the top of the show
another slurring and huffing and puffing
visibly confused moment from Donald
Trump
these are adding up there's multiple of
these per weekend and if you you know in
a sense the most benign explanation is
Trump is merely such a narcissist
focused only on himself that he just
doesn't care to remember all of the
other terrible storms that have happened
during his presidency in a sense it's
the most benign but it also is the one
indicative of the worst person possible
cognitive decline doesn't mean you're a
bad person memory issues don't mean
you're a bad person simply not caring
about other people is something where we
could say wow he really just doesn't
seem like a good guy which of course
would not come as a shock to anybody
who's been following this guy for the
last 10 or 20 years or however long he's
been around and notable in New York City
real estate I don't want to overstate
the importance of the growing Donald
Trump battle with Fox News
because Trump and Fox News getting along
slightly less well as I've been telling
you that they're getting along slightly
less well it doesn't really alter that
in the big picture when you zoom out Fox
carries water or Trump most hosts still
worship the guys every word you've got
Hannity Tucker Jeanine Pirro whatever
Trump might even see the increasing
battle that he has with Fox News really
only Shepard Smith and sometimes Chris
Wallace and some of the weekend hosts
Trump might even see it as sport and a
way to get publicity by attacking Fox
but the reality is that we don't want to
overstate the importance of that
conflict between Trump and some elements
of Fox News because overall they're
still on the same page and Fox is mostly
a pro Trump propaganda outlet but the
disagreements between Fox and Trump have
now spread beyond just Shepard Smith and
occasionally Chris Wallace and once I
believe Neil Cavuto even now Brett Bayer
is having reporter John Roberts simply
say Donald Trump's bogus sharpie altered
map of Hurricane durian is merely that
it's bogus it was never part of the
original forecast now I already told you
in the last story exactly how this map
was presented Donald Trump previously
saying Hurricane Dorian was on track to
hit Alabama
it wasn't Trump then tried to retro
actively defend that claim by using a
Sharpie not saying he personally did it
but someone did to make it look as
though Alabama was within the reasonable
cone or trajectory of that hurricane Fox
News then reported on this and they
didn't fall for it they said this was a
bogus altered map
take a look John you were in the Oval
Office today for that pool spray this
afternoon the president displaying a
hurricane forecast map but there
appeared to be a change made to it what
would happen this was following a
briefing from Kevin Mack Alena and the
Acting Secretary of Homeland Security in
as well to comment out of the Coast
Guard this is a forecast track that the
president held up from last week where
it looked like the hurricane was going
to slamming to the Florida coast maybe
even crossed the potential and get into
the Gulf of Mexico you can see somebody
with
Arpi or some other writing instrument
added a little bit to the code of
uncertainty which was not part of the
official forecast which included the
Florida Panhandle in parts of Alabama
President Trump had tweeted over the
weekend that Alabama appeared to be in
the crosshairs and you could probably
extrapolate that if it had have
continued on that track Alabama might
have been affected but it was never part
of the official forecast when asked this
afternoon how that marking got on the
map the president said he had no idea
right okay John Roberts live in the
North Lawn John thank you this is
hilarious but I really want to make an
effort to provide the right context for
these stories okay when it comes to this
fox versus trump thing let me zoom out a
little bit Fox News and even corporate
media more broadly are what we call
sense making tools and they are terrible
sense making tools for society so when
we talk about sense making and media
this is maybe one of the most important
analyses that we can do and I get it we
started with a sharpie but again I'm
making an effort to really provide
broader and important context through
when we do these media analyses stories
when we talk about the sense making
analysis for media it goes well beyond
the propaganda value of media we've
talked a lot about the propaganda value
of media and how media can sort of serve
corporate interests or political
interests for one party or another party
and you really have to zoom out to
understand this we are an estimated on
this planet we are an estimated seven
point seven billion people each kind of
existing in our little corner of it only
having an awareness of a tiny tiny
fraction each day of what happens on our
planet a nearly infinite I know that
that's not a precise term nearly
infinite but I think people know what I
mean a nearly infinite number of things
takes place every day depending on how
you measure them births deaths violence
storms crimes entrepreneurship food
growing medicine technology right I mean
it's like the list doesn't do it justice
because think about everything that goes
on in our planet in one day sense-making
is giving meaning to what goes on in our
world so that we can understand it
because again so much happens every day
that the
mine cannot actually comprehend it so
sense-making is giving meaning to things
that are going on and this is actually
what corporate media serves on a plate
for us we can't possibly follow every
development that takes place on our
planet
so what media does is not only do they
explain things to us but they also
narrow the scope of what we pay
attention to and by virtue of that they
assign meaning to what areas of life
should we be paying attention to local
news your 11:00 p.m. local news takes
everything that happened in the day and
it makes sense of the world by picking
you know it's usually like five stories
one or two are usually about some
horrible crime that took place they give
you the weather and then a couple of
other stories and that's how they make
sense of the day for you and as I've
talked about countless times about
corporate media there is really no one
media outlet including me I mean I'm
including myself in this there is no one
media outlet that can really do sense
making justice because there's just too
much that happens in the world so to be
an informed person I've talked about the
knowledge pyramid before often times
when I go in I talk to at colleges and
universities about critical thinking and
epistemology the knowledge pyramid is
this thing that you have to build up and
the bottom of the pyramid is critical
thinking skills
epistemology skills learning how to
think learning how to learn you then
build the pyramid further by taking
those epistemological skills and you
want to gain subject matter knowledge
about sociology culture physics math
whatever right you get subject matter
knowledge and then at the very top of
the pyramid is sort of like what happens
day to day you have to use that entire
base of the pyramid to interpret a
specific event to solve a specific math
problem for example when you think about
knowledge this way Fox News calling
Trump out or not calling Trump out
really doesn't make a big difference in
terms of Fox's bigger picture sense
making capacity but when we think of the
universe in which your average trumpets
is operating people who don't have the
epistemology and critical thinking found
a
people who have not used that foundation
because they don't have it to gain
subject matter knowledge for them their
pyramid is truncated and in those cases
it actually can make a difference that
Fox News is saying the Sharpie image was
completely bogus it could pierce
someone's echo-chamber
it could get someone to rethink their
sense making choices and it is still a
good thing that is a lot of context but
this is I think how we need to be
thinking about this very public sort of
pseudo battle between Donald Trump and
Fox News and Fox News occasionally
saying what you are saying there isn't
true what Donald Trump said simply
doesn't correspond to the facts and I
think that if we want to be informed
news consumers and really be thinking
about these things more broadly it's fun
to watch Shep Smith say Trump's a liar
but we want to actually understand the
context and in the context for an
audience that is so lacking that
critical thinking pyramid and the
subject matter knowledge it could
actually get them to say you know what
maybe this guy is a liar and I shouldn't
support him in 2020 and to that extent I
think it's great let's just not pretend
that Fox News is not still 95 percent
carrying water for Donald Trump and
effectively functioning as state media
there's no way to introduce this next
story other than simply to tell you what
happened which is that Donald Trump
congratulated Poland on the 80th
anniversary of World War two of course
the Holocaust sort of started with
Germany's invasion of Poland it's not
exactly something to be congratulating
them about other leaders sent messages
of somber remembrance and reflection
some even warning about sliding back
towards the type of authoritarianism
that we saw early in the third Nazi
Reich but Trump congratulate SPO 'land
for having been invaded by Germany 80
years ago take a look at this yeah
I do have a great message for bowling
that we have Mike Pence our vice
president is just about landing right
now and he is representing me I look
forward to being there soon but I just
want to congratulate Boland it's a great
country with great people we also have
many Polish people in our country it
could be eight million
we love our Polish friends and I will be
there soon
there is no question I mean the analysis
here is very simple
Trump has no idea what Poland's role was
in world war two he just had no idea
what the historical context was so he
said I congratulate them I mean just he
just doesn't know anything that's it
Trump was going to go to Poland for the
world war two remembrance he cancelled
the trip because of Hurricane Dorian so
he was asked instead for a message on
this anniversary of a very very dark day
for Poland back in 1939 and his message
was congratulations what was possibly
the darkest day in Polish history and
Donald Trump congratulate s' them this
is indistinguishable from satire if I
said to someone what's the worst
possible thing you could say to Poland
on the 80th anniversary of being raped
and pillaged by the Nazis
congratulations would be pretty high on
the list he does not know what happened
in World War two period Poland lost 1/5
of its population during World War two a
much bigger percentage of the Jewish
population was lost in Poland during
World War two congratulations guys a
message of congratulations this is not
very different than congratulating
Israel on Holocaust Remembrance Day I
mean it's absolutely in total idiocy the
the only other possibility I can think
of and tell me what you think about this
Trump saying this happened because he
doesn't know what happened to Poland in
World War two is one explanation there's
a more sinister one though which is that
Trump knows Germany invaded Poland in
World War two and he likes it I don't
actually think that that's what's going
on here I don't I try not to attribute
to malice what can be more than
adequately explained by stupidity and
and in this case Trump has shown and
demonstrated over the last many years no
knowledge of history whatsoever and so I
would attribute this to ignorance and
not malice we're only a few days from
the 9/11 anniversary
what is Donald Trump liable to say then
not good not good make sure you're
following me on Instagram at David
Pakman and while you are there follow
the show on instagram at david pakman
show we will take a quick break our long
form deep dive into the regulation of
social media is coming up next really
really important topic and then much
more coming up after that it's not going
to come as a surprise to most people in
our audience that when it comes to
factual knowledge right now we have a
president that doesn't know much about
economics doesn't know much about trade
doesn't know much about currency doesn't
know much about finances or debt other
than personal debt or credit or jobs or
any of it but that has not stopped
President Trump from having very strong
opinions about all of these things for
sure but in addition to not knowing
about any of these things Donald Trump
has another interesting quality which is
that he's completely out of touch with
the average American so in other words
because he's been rich for a long time
he got rich by building a business well
his family was already rich he
personally built his wealth by creating
a business on the back of a small loan
of a million dollars from his dad and
then even more money from his dad you
have to take that privileged status and
combine it with his ignorance on so many
of these financial issues and that's
where you really get an understanding
that Donald Trump by the combination of
lacking knowledge and being completely
out of touch with the way that the
average person lives he can't possibly
understand your financial situation and
clearly he doesn't understand your
financial situation here is Donald Trump
being asked about recession recession
fears have no fear Walmart is doing well
Trump says and everyone's rich so how
could we possibly end up with a
recession I don't think we're having a
reset
we're doing tremendously well our
consumers are rich I gave a tremendous
tax cut and they load it up with money
they're buying I saw the Walmart numbers
they were through the roof just two days
ago that's better than any poll that's
better than any economist and most
economist actually say fill that we're
not going to have a recession most of
them say we're not going to have a
recession but the rest of the world is
not doing well like we're doing the rest
of the world if you look at Germany if
you look at European Union frankly look
at the UK I mean look at a lot of
countries they're not doing well China
is doing poorly parts of Asia are doing
poorly right Walmart's doing well and
people are rich so everything's fine and
a recession would be impossible this is
what happens when you combine total
ignorance on all things economic with
weaponized narcissism and the life of
blinding privilege literally blinding
privilege that blinds him from
understanding what the world is like for
most people now what's fascinating is
that Donald Trump isn't merely saying
there can be no recession he's saying if
there is one on the off chance that
there is one it will have been the
media's fault as an attempt to get him
to lose the 20/20 election so we can now
continue to build our picture ignorant
on all financial and economic related
matters blinded by ignorance weaponized
narcissism and a level of paranoia that
rises to the level of diagnostic if
there were to be a recession we would
blame the media who has been reporting
on me in such a way to cause the economy
to go into a recession this is the trend
under Donald Trump stocks did well this
month Oh Donald Trump deserves the
credit of course stocks did poorly this
month it was the Fed it was the media it
was China it was whoever the president
can think of but the most disappointing
and outrageous thing is this idea that
everybody is doing well financially
Trump doesn't see and when I when I say
that I don't mean he refuses to
recognize he's just not exposed to the
reality that 40% of Americans can't
afford an unexpected $400 expense
without having to go into debt take out
a loan but
a payday loan place borrow money or
whatever the case may be start charging
stuff at interest Trump sees his cabinet
his golf members his family the people
he interacts with every day and that's
it everybody's rich how could we
possibly have a recession when Trump
excuse me when Trump says everyone is
rich I guess he means everyone that
matters to him is rich everyone that he
needs to please is rich so there's the
message from Donald Trump we definitely
would not be having a recession because
everybody's rich but if we did it would
be normal because other countries are
having recessions and it would be the
fault of the Fed and China and the media
definitely not his fault if that were to
happen this count'em we've fallen so far
in terms of what counts as political
positioning and discussion in 2019
America that that position counts as a
political position
Trump's been doing great and stocks are
flying high except when they're not it's
because of the Fed and China and the
fake news media whenever I see these
headlines Trump says can't have a
recession because everyone's rich I
still have a reaction in my brain deep
in my brain that is a pre Trump reaction
which is there is no way that an
American president would ever say this
and that's by the way after having lived
through two terms of George W Bush I
still have that reaction in my brain
Trump used a sharpie or someone in
Trump's administration use the sharpie
to change the path of Hurricane Dorian
on a chart which we'll get to later that
can't be true oh but it is it is true
and then I look at the quote or I look
at the video or I hear from one of
Donald Trump's flunkies and not only are
the headlines
typically accurate the reality of
actually reading the quotes are looking
at the video are often even worse than
the headlines even suggest I hope that
his voters will hold them accountable
now I don't want a recession I know that
there's a contingent on the left very
small that wants a recession in order to
remove Donald Trump that's not me
there's a big contingent of the right
that claims much of the Left wants a
recession to remove Trump that's based
on a completely false assessment of the
left I want a good economy if we get one
and Donald Trump is reelected or not
re-elected the economy being good is
good for many people even though it
still doesn't work for tens of millions
of Americans if we do get a recession I
still don't want one if Donald Trump
supporters recognize that it's because
of him at least partially that the
recession was precipitated then the
question becomes will that make them
vote for a Democrat because if not then
it's all merely academic and
hypothetical so that's what I want to
talk about next how are consumers as
Donald Trump refers to them feeling
about not only the state of the economy
but Donald Trump's role in it now and
his potential role in a future recession
so I got a ton of tweets over the
weekend that we're asking me hey David
are you going to be at the straight
Pride Parade in Boston this weekend it's
happening you should be there you should
interview people you should counter
protests or whatever because you live in
Boston anyway and no I didn't go for
safety reasons because I didn't want to
give it any attention I ended up
actually being out of the city anyway as
I often am both during the weekend and
after the during the weekend but this is
not an event that appealed to me the
event happened there were straight Pride
Parade errs there were counter
protesters actually more counter
protesters than paraders there was a
massive police presence my contacts in
law enforcement and the Intel community
told me that they were really busy
managing all of the different threats
and extremist groups that were expected
to come in there were more people
protesting the parade than people
marching for straight pride in total
there were about 35 verse 36 arrests in
total I don't know what percentage of
those arrests were marchers vs. counter
protesters I'm guessing at some point
soon we will have that information the
marchers definitely had some themes in
their messages support our troops was a
theme build the wall was a theme great
to be straight is a theme a lot of pro
Trump stuff just make America great
again and this type of thing some people
were hurt nine people ended up at area
hospitals so people here already know my
feelings about this type of parade in
general
Pride Parade is unnecessary in the sense
that it's not just if you have a gay
pride parade then obviously everything's
fine and you should have a straight
Pride Parade the idea behind a gay pride
parade is that we are talking about it
historically marginalized and
discriminated against group whose place
in society good people want to affirm
most people are straight people don't
get fired for being straight straight
people have always been able to get
married to those to whom they are
attracted I don't even want to dignify
that part any further the idea of you
know a white pride group a white student
union or whatever as the same thing as a
Latino Student Union well you're not
talking about a historically
marginalized and oppressed group and we
have to really examine what the
motivations are of a lot of those groups
and the motivations aren't good okay
so that that's where we're going to stop
with that analysis because it's such a
stupid analysis that it doesn't even
need to be done one reason I didn't go
is I don't want to give them attention
I think counter protesting is totally
valid but they aren't really marching
for straight pride they are marching to
anger people they are marching to
trigger and own the libs as they'd like
to say and some of them are marching
because they genuinely struggle with
their masculinity but that's a whole
other story which we're not going to
talk about today very few of them
actually show up to this stuff to really
protest and again there were more
counter protesters this time around what
would happen if nobody showed up to
counter protest and however many people
I don't even know how many marchers
there were was it a few dozen was it a
hundred people a couple I don't know
imagine if no one gave them any
attention they show up they march around
with their maggots and their build the
wall signs and they're totally ignored
no one protests no one cares no one
tries to fight the permit for the parade
they are just ignored no one writes
about it they are irrelevant I think
that that actually is a really great
scenario now again I was out of town
anyway and there were all sorts of
security concerns in terms of some of
the extremist groups that were coming in
but these are just
all groups of people doing really dumb
things what if we did just ignore them
now other perspectives are valid it when
when Bernie Sanders chose to do a
FoxNews Town Hall the idea being I'm
gonna go right in there and talk
directly to people who might be on the
right and maybe I can convince them and
Elizabeth Warren said I'm not going to
participate at all because I don't want
to dignify in some sense hate for-profit
Fox News and give them ratings both of
those perspectives are valid I respect
what Elizabeth Warren did and I think
Bernie Sanders crushed it in his debate
but both are valid approaches in the
same way you can take the perspective
that a large showing of peace and love
by counter protesters at the straight
Pride Parade is the best way to fight
against the message of the straight
Pride Parade that's fine I opted for a
different path and I wonder if every
time they tried to organize one of these
they just get the permit and nobody
cares people go and do other things they
go to the music great museums in Boston
they go to all of the different great
things that there are to do in Boston
and they just don't give any attention
to these people would they keep doing
these parades something tells me that
they probably would not they would not
be doing this if no one paid attention
because the whole point of it is to get
attention so I didn't go I wasn't there
I was out of the city in any case but I
would not have gone if I was in town to
be totally honest with you